the covid infection rate here is the
highest it's been since christmas
the rise in infections one in every 65
people in wales had covered in the first
few days of september it's put their
health system under huge pressure
the country's leaders have warned 100
people a day will need hospital
treatment
in the coming weeks
until now
this rise has been manageable
but with a rapid spread of coronavirus
in our communities
pandemic pressure on the nhs
is increasing once again
in scotland infections are soaring too
the highest since estimates began last
october
rising cases have prompted the country
to introduce mandatory vaccine passports
more interventions have not been ruled
out
in england there has been no rise or
fall in the number of infections
it's one less thing for doctors like
rosie brooks to worry about
next week her surgery should be starting
its winter flu campaign but that's been
put on hold until the government decides
what to do about covered boosters
we haven't been told whether it's safe
to give them together in theory it makes
sense but we need to be given the
absolute sign off on that we can't just
go ahead and do what we think is right
what sort of pressure does that place on
your
surgery it's a lot more work once
they've geared up to come in for a
vaccine it's nice to just get both done
there and then
the government says it's waiting for the
jcvi to advise
before making the call
the concerns expressed here are caused
by the uncertainties the not knowing and
they'll be shared in surgeries and
clinics across the country patients are
asking questions and for now there are
no answers to give them
while britain waits other countries are
making choices the prime minister
learning from his chilean counterpart
about their inoculation program
i think that
uh you're you're now going to vaccinate
uh
younger people as well exactly yeah we
started with children three years old
until 11. my goodness right
as the government fends off criticism of
stalling the rest of us have taken our
first tentative steps back
towards normality
the end of the first full week of a
return to work for many people
has passed
key decisions to safeguard our futures
have yet to be taken
josh's sky news